[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend im
donbass läuft es nicht gut für die
ukrainischen truppen umso drängender
berufe um hilfe und natürlich richten
sich die blicke wieder auf deutschland
eines der größten industrieländer mit
einer der größten rüstungsindustrie eine
europäische großmacht die besonders enge
beziehungen zu russland pflegte das und
die von vielen als zögerlich empfundenen
reaktion auf den krieg hat die deutsche
außenpolitik in eine missliche lage
gebracht in der ukraine in osteuropa im
baltikum ist inzwischen offen von
vertrauensverlust die rede vor diesem
hintergrund trat heute der bundeskanzler
in davos auf anne gellinek berichtet es
ist vielleicht ein zufall des kalenders
aber irgendwie auch symbolisch dass der
kanzler als letzter kommt zum
weltwirtschaftsforum der ukraine krieg
hat das treffen der elite aus wirtschaft
finanzwelt und politik fünf tage lang
beherrscht das rätselraten über die
kommunikation der deutschen regierung zu
waffenlieferungen auch sonst tut so als
gäbe es keine debatte über die
verschleppungstaktik der deutschen und
arbeitet sich stattdessen an putin ab
ist unser ziel ganz klar
putin darf seinen krieg nicht gewinnen
und ich bin überzeugt er wird ihn nicht
gewinnen schon jetzt hat er alle seine
strategischen ziele verfehlt die ukraine
dagegen sind mit einer riesigen
delegation in die schweizer berge
gereist und bespielen das davoser forum
virtuos video schalten mit dem
präsidenten die klitschko brüder mit
emotionalen auftritten
höhepunkt ist ein treffen zwischen rund
50 internationalen firmenchefs mit
ukrainischen vertretern samt außen und
premierminister es geht um den
wiederaufbau des landes
aussenminister kollegah sagt er wolle
nicht mehr über waffenlieferungen reden
tut es aber natürlich trotzdem
wir haben inzwischen verstanden dass
deutschland nicht das land sein wird
dass eine führungsrolle bei den
waffenlieferungen übernehmen wird aber
klar ist auch wenn wir keine schweren
waffen bekommen werden wir getöteten
gibt harry web und web load olaf scholz
versucht bei seinem auftritt die
aufmerksamkeit auf das eigentliche thema
zu lenken weltwirtschaft lieferketten
globalisierung kritik an china wegen der
menschenrechtsverletzungen an den
uiguren jahr aber einen rückbau der
globalisierung können es nicht geben um
es ganz klar zu sagen die die
globalisierung ist ein holzweg sie wird
nicht funktionieren
der appell europäische werte künftig
über die profite zu stellen verhallt in
den gängen des davoser kongresszentrums
weitgehend ungehört ein firmenchef
dessen konzern in china viel geld
verdient setzt auf das prinzip hoffnung
handel und kommunikation und aktivitäten
in den anderen ländern führen dazu dass
wir vielleicht eine chance haben die
anderen länder in diese richtung zu
bewegen china hat sich schon viel
geöffnet es gibt sicherlich auch in
vehlen und kinder wird sich auch wieder
öffnen
das wegbrechen alter gewissheiten hat
die teilnehmer des davoser treffens
dieses jahr nervös gemacht die weltlage
schwierig wie nie die zu lösenden
probleme auch der kanzler kam spät aber
das ist ja vielleicht nur ein zufall des
kalenders
anne gellinek in da wo es wie nur dann
die rede von kanzler scholz aufgenommen
in davos also neuigkeiten im engeren
sinne hatte er ja anscheinend nicht im
gepäck
nein olaf scholz hat einen breiten bogen
in seiner rede geschlagen von der
ukraine über den klimawandel bis hin zum
g7-treffen in deutschland im nächsten
monat und er hat meiner einschätzung
nach eine chance vertan einer
internationalen einem internationalen
publikum und auch der großen
ukrainischen delegation seine politik zu
erklären wir haben in den letzten tagen
mit vielen menschen hier auf dem
weltwirtschaftsforum in den gängen
gesprochen und viele davon waren sehr
erstaunt darüber dass so ein großes und
wichtiges land wie deutschland so
verdruckst und chaotisch beim thema
waffenlieferungen kommuniziert und sie
hatten wohl klare ansagen heute von olaf
scholz erwartet die blieb er aber
schuldig er hat das thema komplett
ignoriert in seiner rede bei seinem
blitzbesuch in davos er hat nur gesagt
deutschland liefere waffen auch schweres
gerät und auf deutschland sei verlass
punkt daran gibt es ja durchaus zweifel
also gerade das osteuropa wird ja auch
immer lauter kritik geübt an deutschland
denkt man schon den
verteidigungsminister lettlands der
kürzlich sagte im zuge des ukrainisch
krieges sei im baltikum das vertrauen in
deutschland 90 gerutscht und der
ukrainische aussenminister eben in einem
bericht der klang ja fast so als habe er
deutschland abgeschrieben
ja und nein beim thema waffenlieferungen
ist es tatsächlich so dass deutschland
auch auf europäischer ebene nicht mehr
ernst genommen wird der ukrainische
aussenminister sagte hier in davos er
habe inzwischen ein gewisses sportliches
interesse entwickelt die debatte zu
verfolgen weil er doch gerne wissen
wollen wie die ausgänge und ob jemals
waffen in der ukraine eintreffen aber
bei einem anderen thema was hier sehr im
vordergrund stand nämlich der
wiederaufbau in der ukraine da sind die
deutschen nicht abgeschrieben rechnet
man natürlich weiterhin mit der starken
deutschen finanzkraft und mit deutschen
unternehmen dankeschön für die
einschätzungen
die ukraine kämpfte um ihre
unabhängigkeit um ihr überleben und mit
ihr bank weitere länder in der region
die befürchten müssen dass sie die exten
opfer sein könnten georgien moldau und
mit der ukraine bank auch die
demokratiebewegung in belarus von
diktator lukaschenko wurde sie zwar
brutal niedergeschlagen aber es gibt sie
noch manche bälle russen kämpfen jetzt
sogar an der seite ukrainischer soldaten
und immer noch erheben die drei frauen
die zum gesicht der belarussischen
opposition wurden ihre stimmen zumindest
svetlana d janowski und veronika z carlo
die im exil leben die dritte maria
kolesnikova sitzt weiter im gefängnis
allen dreien wurde heute der
internationale karlspreis verliehen jena
kwon berichtet
free kolesnikova ein dringender appell
sie nicht zu vergessen die einzige
preisträgerin die heute bei der
verleihung im aachener rathaus nicht
dabei sein kann es ist eine auszeichnung
die auch im zeichen des ukraine krieg
steht sagt die oppositionspolitikerin
svetlana die hall of skye
als der krieg ausbrach hat dass vieles
für die bälle russische bevölkerung
verändert auch für unseren kampf denn
jetzt müssen wir nicht nur gegen die
diktatur und tyrannei in unserem land
kämpfen sondern auch an der seite der
ukraine wir müssen die ukraine
verteidigen denn unsere schicksale sind
miteinander verbunden
sie wurden zu den bekanntesten
gesichtern der belarussischen
massenproteste forderten lukaschenko
heraus trotz der staatlichen willkür im
autoritären regime
sich yanofsky die als siegerin der
umstrittenen wahl 2020 hervorging lebt
im exil genauso wie ihre freundin
veronika zepp carlo
maria kohl s nikkor war hingegen blieb
und wurde zu elf jahren lagerhaft
verurteilt aus dem gefängnis in minsk
sendet sie herzen bis heute ihr
markenzeichen
beim karlspreis in aachen wird sie von
ihrer schwester vertreten
ich weiß dass es für meine schwester
nicht einfach ist in gefahr es schon
seit fast 20 monaten ist sie dort aber
sie bleibt stark
auch der vater alexander kolesnikov ist
stolz auf mascha wie er seine tochter
nennt der letzte besuch im gefängnis
liegt schon monate zurück und erinnert
ihn immer wieder daran wie sehr er seine
tochter vermisst
es war schön die anwesenheit des anderen
spüren zu können am meisten berührt hat
mich ein kurs durch die scheiben
hindurch die nicht zustande gekommene
umarmung fühle ich bis heute briefe sind
das einzige kommunikationsmittel das uns
geblieben ist
eine unglaubliche geschichte die über
die grenzen von belarus hinaus die
menschen inspiriert
außenministerin annalena baerbock hält
heute in aachen die laudatio würdigte
den mut der drei frauen
armut lässt sich nicht wegsperren die
idee der freiheit kann man nicht ins
exil vertreiben
drei belarussische frauen als vorbild
für viele menschen die heute ein zeichen
setzen für frieden in europa
und die nachrichten beginnen jetzt mit
dem kriegsgeschehen
russische truppen haben nach
ukrainischen angaben mehr als 40 städte
im donbass angegriffen und bedrohen
damit den letzten großen fluchtweg für
die zivilbevölkerung aus dem osten der
ukraine
der ukrainische präsident selensky
erklärte die russischen soldaten seien
den eigenen truppen in einigen teilen
des ostens zahlenmäßig weit überlegen im
gebiet lohans sind sie während dortmund
ist offenbar die letzten großen städte
die noch von ukrainischen truppen
gehalten werden
die us regierung will nach den worten
von aussenminister blinken trotz putins
krieg in der ukraine auch weiterhin auf
die größte langfristige herausforderung
für die internationale ordnung
konzentriert bleiben und die gehe von
der volksrepublik china aus in einer
grundsatzrede zur china politik sagte
blinken china habe sowohl die absicht
die internationale ordnung umzugestalten
und zunehmend auch die wirtschaftliche
diplomatische militärische und
technologische macht die um dies zu tun
blinken versicherte gleichzeitig die usa
seien nicht auf einen konflikt aus
das polnische parlament hat die
abschaffung der umstrittenen
disziplinarkammer am obersten
gerichtshof beschlossen die eu
kommission hatte die disziplinarkammer
als gefahr für die unabhängigkeit der
richter gewertet und die auflösung
gefordert die parlamentsentscheidung
dürfte dann auch thema sein beim für
kommende woche geplanten polen besuch
von kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
in berlin hat ein zweitägiges treffen
der energie umwelt und klima minister
der g7 staaten begonnen deutschland hat
derzeit den g7 vorsitz
bundeswirtschafts- und klimaschutz
minister habe warnte davor klima und
energiekrise gegeneinander auszuspielen
vielmehr müssten sie gemeinsam gelöst
werden und umweltministerin lemke sagte
es gebe weder zeit noch ressourcen die
krisen nacheinander zu lösen
eine meldung vom sport die deutsche
eishockey nationalmannschaft ist bei der
weltmeisterschaft in helsinki im
viertelfinale am team tschechiens
gescheitert mannschaft von bundestrainer
thomas wördehoff verlor mit 1 zu 4 und
jetzt die wetteraussichten für die
kommenden tage morgen erwartet uns
windiges teils stürmisches wetter mit
einzelnen gewittern im norden und
schauern im osten sonst bleibt es
trocken bei 16 bis 23 grad in den
nächsten tagen ist es überwiegend kühl
mit schauern dabei ist es im süden meist
trocken 12 bis 21 grad
wenn die party tanz technisch nicht so
richtig in schwung kommt aber geht immer
also zumindest aus meiner generation
aufwärts aber achtung bevor sich die
millenials jetzt milde lächelnd abwenden
diese vier mittlerweile ehrwürdigen
senioren haben gerade so ziemlich das
futuristische life ging auf die bühne
gebracht dass man sich vorstellen kann
eine digitale zeitreise zurück in die
siebziger mit avataren
so richtig vorstellen kann man es sich
ja nicht aber andreas stamm zeigt uns
wie das aussieht in london ist heute
premiere
das schwedische königspaar im londoner
east end da kündigt sich großes an es
ist fantastisch so viele generationen
jeder liebt aber
auch die wartenden fans aus aller welt
wollen die bert
werden erhört erstmals seit jahrzehnten
zeigt sich das quartett vereint für eine
zeitreise in die eigene vergangenheit
wir sind glücklich wieder zusammen zu
sein und zu arbeiten wie nach hause
kommen
auf dem weg am auto da fühlte es sich an
als ob ich wieder auf mein konzert gehen
ich bin sehr nervös
gleichzeitig sehr aufgeregt und ich habe
es noch nicht sehen können
zu sehen eine musikalische
wiederauferstehung
[Musik]
sein
das erste konzert seit 40 jahren die
originalstimmen
ihre bewegungen alles aber
alles nur nicht die helden der 70er
popmusik konserviert als hologramm
[Musik]
es regiert die illusion eines realen
konzert ich habe bei den oben menschen
gesehen die das völlig gekauft haben die
mit den hologrammen eine abmachung
getroffen haben ja ja ich will glauben
das aber wirklich hier sind für die
eineinhalbstündige show was real ist es
nicht verschwimmt vernichtet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein fast 1000 köpfiges team hat in fünf
jahren die avatare auferstehen lassen
eine digitale projektion der band von
1979 mit 160 kameras wurden die konzert
songs mit den originalen wochen lang
gefilmt danach digitalisiert verjüngen
zu einer show verschmolzen
[Applaus]
um ein gefühl zurück zu bringen
400 millionen verkaufte alben
[Musik]
vier gut gelaunte schweden aus dem
pop-olymp
bis zum ende in tränen
anfang der 80er band aus er aus die
beiden paare lassen sich scheiden
[Musik]
privat war es das musikalisch gelingt
dem vergangenen herbst mit dem album
watch das comeback feldtoren wollen sie
nie wieder dafür kann die gesamte halle
ab und anderen ort wieder aufgebaut
werden sollte die für immer jung show in
london ein kassenschlager werden
dieser internet
denkt hier vor sie musik ist dann
natürlich der satz der fallen muss von
uns war es das schon für heute und
gleich geht es bei markus lanz weiter
und der nächste heute express gibt es
dann gegen mitternacht das morgen auf
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]